now the next year 2016 the debates about
Britain's membership of the European
Union looks set to come to a head the
promised in art referendum could come as
early as June and there's a warning this
morning from Euroskeptic conservatives
than normal auen government ministers to
campaign freely on the issue could cause
a damaging split within the party when
I'm joined now by one of the grandees of
that party it's fair to say the former
Chancellor Kenneth Clark he's in
Nottingham and a very good morning to
you mr. Clark simple question to start
with them how do you think the Prime
Minister did in Brussels I think of him
pretty well I mean the delivery is he is
very go to present it when he's in the
middle of the negotiation the three big
items he's made great progress on of
course all the euro skeptic press lose
interest in and they put in the bag and
that's quite disproportionate amount of
intentions being paid on what was
actually the detail of his benefit
proposals but at by and large I think
what it showed was a genuine desire to
reach a pragmatic solution to all this
and negotiated solution very heavily
giving David the great bulk of what he
wants and they will be getting be able
to get on to the real debate about
Britain's role in the world and
Britain's membership of the European
Union but on this set this set key issue
seems to be the sticking point in you of
all people understand how economies work
people are saying people within your own
party is saying even if he gets it's not
clear he will this four-year freeze on
benefits for EU nationals arriving in
the UK de the national living wage the
new minimum wage will negate all that
that will be the Paul factor well it's
not the key issue the benefit of
entitlement of people lawfully living
here and in work and working alongside
English people it's a difficult
proposition that if your foreign both
though your lawfully employed your
Lithuanian working alongside the
Englishman should have less take-home
pay because the benefit and tax system
should discriminate against him he won't
get that I never thought that he would
what he's interested
is trying to discourage the level of
migration having some protection against
the level of migration although of
course the lawful migration of people
coming from the continent to work here
often with skills we haven't got often
with jobs in the health services on is
not the biggest problem we have of
immigration the biggest problem is the
unlawful immigration and also the sudden
surge in migration from war zones across
Europe coming here coming to cali and
all the rest of it where we got to work
with the others any way to get that back
under control because we're all
vulnerable to it so let's just be clear
you're saying he won't get this
four-year benefits freeze and it does
seem it seems to be coming from from
Downing Street that this is D but he
might have a key issue it's not the key
issue he's never said it's the key issue
with the key the issue he's wanting to
have that address by putting that
forward is the level of migration from
the European Union and that that's the
one where they r is room for debate
about the extent to which an individual
member state should be able to control
that if some really difficult
circumstances arrive but I mean you have
to think about it against in both ways
we have 2 million british people living
in the rest of the EU and so anything we
propose it's in theory possible for
governments in the other EU countries to
start discriminating against our
nationals young people living and
working in Paris Berlin Rome etc people
who've retired two houses in France or
Spain and all the rest of it we don't
want them discriminated against so
you've got to find some other way I
think of giving in extremists some
control over it if you can but isn't
even the biggest part of our migration
problem biggest part of our migration
problem is illegal people coming from
Africa and with assumed identities
because they're so desperate to improve
their lifestyle and find work and all
the people pouring out of war zones in
Syria and Iraq and Somalia in Eritrea
most of whom want to go to Germany and
Sweden but quite a number of whom
want to come here and get here and it
that needs cooperation between nation
states and the european union which is
facing in a huge immediate crisis we all
need to get together to decide how we
can stop people surging across the
continent Howie at the same time can do
act to in a humanitarian way to resettle
people displaced by wars in which we're
taking part in which the British are
taking part you can't bomb Syria and say
we have no responsibility whatever for
the Syrian refugees from the warfare and
if the referendum does come next year
how do you think it'll play out in your
own party can I just put you some of the
comments written in the paper today by
your your colleague Liam Fox dr. Fox
says that the Prime Minister will start
a civil war and damage the premiership
of his leadership if he treats your a
skeptics as idiots during the referendum
campaign well I'm sometimes careless
with like la which I didn't regard
people like Liam false as idiots what
he's actually said because the body is
divided those has been but we should
treat each other with respect which I
think we do I never expected to be on
the same side of the referendums Liam
Fox the day that David announced it he
knew that the big conservatives on both
sides of the campaign he did it largely
because he wanted to manage debate in
the party which he thought was getting
out of hand and to give it an outlet as
it were but Liam and I and quite a lot
of my colleagues in the House of Commons
will be on the other side of the great
to me we knew that before we started
that with plenty of ministers on my side
there are a lot of ministers who are
vehemently I cited I think there are
members of the cabinet who sadly more
pro-european than I am and what we've
all got to do is behave sensibly argue
rationally I mean you can be very
critical of the views they hold I mean
your skepticism I think your euphemism
for right-wing nationalism but that
doesn't mean I don't think this all of
them are quite intelligent and sensible
and perfectly nice right-wing
nationalists and get round to the real
arguments the real arguments is how do
we give Britain
bigger voice in the world to look after
our interest in the complicated 21st
century what is the best base for our
economy how do we keep attracting inward
investment jobs modern industries to
this country how do we get an outlet
into the great markets of the world
including Europe which is fifty percent
of our market from most of the things we
actually produce so there and euro
skeptics can argue to the contrary when
we get there we want to have a sensible
debate again going back to your first
questions I think the benefit
entitlement of EU nationals working in
British shops offices and factories will
not be the be all and end or the key
issue that besides the debate it's just
a difficult time at the moment and when
we get back to proportion the huge
significance of the vote and the bigger
issues are what the country has to
address in the interests of future
generations our children and
grandchildren just want to squeeze in a
quick question on another issue mr.
Clarkson former home secretary Justice
Secretary of course some this idea seems
to be floated in the some of the papers
this morning that there should be more
protection or should be looked at giving
more protection to police officers who
use firearms on British streets well I'd
am I looking at it I think the law is
pretty clear actually so long as the
peace officer has a reasonable belief
that he or somebody else is in danger
he's entitled to shoot and week I don't
think we've had any unjust convictions
of any police officers trouble is
nowadays again you know it's the future
of the modern world we all have to live
with including unfortunately sometimes
police officers huge amount of
excitement and campaigning surrounds
every incident so police officers often
have to go through dreadful ordeal of
suspension and possible criticism and
questioning before the fact they did
their duty is established but we don't
want to alter the law to allow please to
shoot at random you ain't got to look
across the Atlantic to some states in
the United States of America
to see that you do need a clear legal
framework and not just the casual use of
weapons this country I think we're very
good and before he shoots a policeman
has to have a reasonable belief that
imminent danger is occurring but any
sensible jury any sensible prosecutor I
hope any sensible member of the public
realizes that sometimes this is an
instant flash decision you can't sit and
wait to see whether the man you're
looking at is about to kill you or kill
somebody else that he's after